everything will be fine Edward feel bad
my bed and be stronger
[Music]
it's pain usually a bit or must be a
side effect of the new venom azad which
means his behind us under the same
string
here's your money come get it
[Music]
catwoman
took you long enough
[Music]
like the view it's the only thing you'll
catch tonight
don't be so sure
is Batman your new boy-toy
I have one too
none of this is my fault
he made me control Superman what's his
name he calls himself hush the events of
the past months reach as high as
Superman and as low as the Joker all
were set into motion by hush
is it too much to ask for one quiet
weekend it's like they're all falling
out from under the carpet
hush nose
he's been one step ahead of me the whole
time
tick-tock trails going home
[Music]
this just gets better and better
hush hush
hi everyone happy Comic Con week if you
guys didn't see they drop Batman hush
while all the craziness was going on we
also have a really big update on the
Robert Pattinson Batman movie that Matt
Reeves is making I'll talk about that
after I talk about Batman hush one of
the best Batman comic book stories of
all time you would think them doing an
animated movie of it would be an easy
slam dunk so we'll break it all down and
some of the comic book changes there
were some small changes and some really
big changes so I will say spoiler
warning when I get to that part will we
do an IMAX ticket giveaways all week
long all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Batman moment on the video this is all
obviously borrowing from the Batman hush
comic book storyline with changes made
because it's within the Justice League
war continuity so this is all taking
place after the events of the death of
Superman than the reign of the Superman
movies if you guys didn't see it they
also dropped an extended preview on
Justice League versus the fatal five
because they've been releasing a whole
bunch of animated movies this year but
the Justice League burst the fatal five
movie is Bruce Timm from Batman animated
series and his crew like Kevin Conroy at
that group of people so that's why the
animation style looks so different and
this is drawn to look more like the
Justice League war films the animation
style they developed for that I'm not as
big a fan of that animation style as I
am of Bruce Tim's but Warner Brothers
animation generally does really really
good work Warner Brothers animated
movies tend to be some of the best DC
movies you will ever wind up seeing but
even if you haven't read the Batman hush
storyline everyone in creation at least
knows a little bit about the story so a
lot of this should feel familiar I'll be
with a few changes that they made there
are a couple of characters that were not
in the comic book story like Damian
Wayne is a big addition to this because
he exists within the Justice League war
continuity he's been a character and
they try to put him in pretty much every
single animated Batman movie that they
do mostly because Damian Wayne is super
popular with their younger audience and
that's where most of this animation
stuff is geared towards but in the
comics Grant Morrison didn't create the
Damian Wayne character till about three
years after they published the Batman
hush comic book storyline the comic book
is over 15 years old so I feel like we
don't really need a spoiler warning for
that
comic book but the character hush Thomas
Eliot is someone from Bruce Wayne's past
that grew up with him that blames him
for all these terrible things that
happened to his life so he wants to make
Batman suffer he finds out that Batman
is Bruce Wayne so he systematically goes
about pitting Batman against all of his
biggest villains that was one of the
coolest things about the Batman hush
comic book is that it wasn't just this
dark person from his past coming back to
fight him it was this dark villain from
his past coming back to set him against
all of his darkest villains to tear him
down systematically until he could
eventually just take his life from him
and become Bruce Wayne literally because
Thomas Eliot surgically alters his face
so that it looks exactly like a copy of
Bruce Wayne's that's why he has the
bandages on his head because it's post
surgery but Jimmy Lee and Jeff Loeb
wanted that big WTF moment at the end of
the story where he unwraps the bandages
and you see Bruce Wayne's face oh my god
is Bruce Wayne oh wait it's Thomas Eliot
wearing Bruce Wayne's face trying to
take his identity most of you will also
probably remember that one of the
coolest things about that story towards
the end is that they also set up Batman
under the Red Hood because he finds
Jayson Todd's grave is empty and then it
sort of sets the stage for Jason Todd to
return as the Red Hood character so he
had this long series of villains from
Batman's past coming back
making him atone for what they consider
his sins to be like you did all these
terrible things we're going to make you
suffer for all the wrongs you visited on
us so this way you're basically gonna
see pretty much every big Batman villain
show up during this movie I will say
spoiler warning talking about the
Riddler stuff because he was one of the
biggest character changes that they made
to the original comic book story The
Riddler already had a really important
role in the original comic book hush
storyline but the movie tries to make
him a way way bigger character than he
was in the comic book so be prepared for
that your enjoyment of the film just
depends on how much you enjoyed these DC
films so if you liked the animated films
since they started the Justice League
war continuity you'll probably enjoy
this because there's just a continuation
of those characters with them adapting
the Batman hush comic book but they have
not announced any kind of Batman under
the Red Hood noob movie the only other
rumor about the next big Batman movie is
it at some point they're gonna do Batman
the long Halloween and cool side note
about the long Halloween storyline
because
so one of the best Batman comic book
stories of all time is it supposedly
Matt Reeves use some of that as the
basis for his Batman movie that he's
doing with Robert Pattinson there's no
big DC movie panel happening this
weekend but the rumor is that Vanessa
Kirby is gonna be Selina Kyle Catwoman
in the Matt Reeves Batman film she's
done a pretty fantastic job in the stuff
that she's been in so far the drama
stuff the big action stuff so I am
intrigued hopefully we'll get a costume
reveal at some point or at least a
costume reveal for Robert Pattinson
'he's new Batman costume because right
now they're saying that it's supposed to
be set sometime during the 90s so it's
almost a prequel of sorts to the modern
Batman films so I'm expecting a much
more pared down version of the more
armored Batman suits that we've seen
with the last couple of iterations like
even Christian Bale's Batman suit wound
up getting pretty armored up by Dark
Knight Rises all the Wonder Woman 1984
trailers the birds-of-prey trailers will
drop a little bit later this year Batman
himself is going to be a character on
Titan season 2 amongst many other new
characters Deathstroke ravager rose
Wilson Jericho Superboy Krypto a whole
bunch of other people there's a rumor
that they're gonna drop that trailer in
the next couple of days because Titan
season 2 premieres September 6 so it's
almost a month away so of course we're
gonna get the trailer really soon I'll
do Easter Egg videos for that as soon as
it drops but also in the DC Universe The
Watchmen HBO TV show is coming later
this year I'll be doing episode videos
for that too I've already done a trailer
video explaining what the continuity is
what the timeline is you can click here
to watch that and click here for my
Marvel phase for Comic Con panel with
all those movies they just announced
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you